[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 nous sommes le jeudi 3 juin voici les
titres de cette édition
après la victoire hier en amical contre
le pays de galles l'équipe de france de
football continue sa préparation pour
l'euro 2020 dans les yvelines et c'est
une tradition depuis 1988 les bleus
s'entraînent à clairefontaine
retour sur cette histoire liée avec le
département et puis leur sera-t-il
événements de relance du football
amateur
nous poserons la question à notre invité
jean-pierre meurillon président du
district des yvelines rencontre avec les
parents de la petite léana 7 yvelinoise
de 11 ans est atteinte d'une maladie
génétique très rare le syndrome cardio
faciaux cutanées comment vit-on sa
parentalité lorsque l'on a un enfant en
situation de handicap portrait à suivre
enfin découverte à la fin de ce journal
de là à tricoter rap il s'agit d'un soin
énergétique du cheveu une méthode qui ne
nécessite aucun produit et qui a pour
objectif d'apporter détente et bien-être
elle nous avons pu la tester à voisins
le bretonneux et ne seront également
tout à l'heure au lycée 17 mar à
maurepas les élèves de l'établissement
ont organisé leur premier éco festival
le but sensibiliser au développement
durable et à la sur la surconsommation
et j - 8 avant le début de l'euro 2020
le match d'ouverture est au programme
vendredi 11 juin turquie italie a depuis
la ville de rome
le tournoi de football reportés à cette
année en raison de la crise sanitaire se
déroulera du 11 juin au 11 juillet et en
tout dans 11 pays différents et pour
préparer l'échéance comme d'habitude les
bleus vont se préparer à clairefontaine
dans les yvelines michael ni d'euros est
avec nous pour parler de cette histoire
dont soir bonsoir
histoire avec le sitv noah qui a débuté
il ya longtemps et justement quand
at-elle débuté cette histoire entre
l'équipe de france et clairefontaine
alors c'est une histoire assez récente
finalement avant l'ouverture de
clairefontaine équipe de france avaient
l'habitude de se rassembler en région
parisienne les blondes par exemple
préparer la coupe du monde 4 ans 1/2 et
l'euro 84 à jouy en josas dans les
yvelines s'est d'ailleurs juste avant
cet euro que la fédération française
achète le domaine de montjoie dans la
forêt de rambouillet pour construire le
centre de clairefontaine sous
l'impulsion de faire un an sastre après
plusieurs années de travaux l'équipe
s'installe officiellement sur le site en
1988 avec une inauguration en grande
pompe par le président de la république
de l'époque françois mitterrand
ils ne quitteront plus clairefontaine
donc une histoire de 30,3 en somme toute
assez longue mais à l'échelle
effectivement l'histoire du football
ciena une histoire assez récente
alors concrètement à quoi sert ce centre
de clairefontaine pour les équipes de
france
alors le centre technique national a
pour objectif de regrouper les équipes
de france de football dans un espace de
performance de 56 hectares dans un écrin
à l'abri des regards et pour la pratique
du haut niveau le site comprend
aujourd'hui cite un de gazon naturel de
terrain en pelouse artificielle des
terrains couverts un gymnase des salles
de musculation
c'est ce vestiaire des piscines d'eau
froide une salle medias des
installations médicales et surtout un
château pouvant abriter des joueurs
pendant les rassemblements et les
compétitions internationales bref tout
est fait pour permettre aux joueurs de
performer et quel est le palmarès des
bleus depuis leur installation à
clairefontaine
l'équipe de france masculine a écrit les
plus belles pages de son histoire sur ce
site il ya bien sûr eu la consécration
un certain 12 juillet 1998 avec la
première victoire de la france à la
coupe du monde les bleus de zidane avait
préparé la compétition et surtout la
finale contre le brésil dans le centre
ville noah pour la petite anecdote 15
arbres ont été plantés sur le site pour
symboliser les quinze buts des bleus
pendant la compétition deux ans plus
tard la france gagne l'euro face à
l'italie il y a eu cette finale de coupe
du monde perdue en 2006 et enfin la
victoire de 2018 la deuxième en coupe du
monde avec la manda griezmann pogba et
bat p au total toutes les équipes de
france de football ont remporté 25
titres depuis l'installation à
clairefontaine et on espère qu'un
nouveau trophée arrivera sur les
étagères cet été après l'euro ne crions
pas victoire trop tôt merci avec les
provinces et villes en tout cas pour
toutes ces explications et jean-pierre
meurillon est avec nous par
visioconférence bonsoir enfin vous êtes
le président du district de football des
yvelines petite réaction déjà à ce que
l'on vient d'entendre être le district
de france qui accueille sur son sol
justement ce centre technique national
de clairefontaine j'imagine que c'est
une fierté
ah ouais c'est une fierté et puis nous
en profitons également puisque on fait
là bas quelques uns un certain nombre de
formations ont fait la barre la
formation de nos arbitres est là bref on
profite de la proximité
le p r pantene vis-à-vis bien sûr le
district peut profiter de ces
installations
cela a rendu possible à votre avis les
victoires de l'équipe de france c'est
une explication ce centre de
clairefontaine qui est alors à proximité
de paris mais qui bénéficie d'un cadre
tranquille pour préparer ces
compétitions
ben quand on connaît à l'installation de
terres fontane oui les joueurs là-bas
ils sont les joueurs et le staff etc
ils sont à l'abri de à l'abri d'où ils
sont loin elles y sont dans la nature
il suffit de visiter que la fontaine
pour comprendre que c'est un plus
et donc avec ses victoires en 98 en 2000
également vous le disiez michael en 2018
ya eu aussi cet euro 2016 qui était en
france avec une accession en finale pour
l'équipe de france alors l'heureux 2020
c'est dans huit jours jean-pierre
meurillon avec ce match d'ouverture en
disait turquie italie à rome
la france elle défiera l'allemagne pour
sa première ce sera le 15 juin à munich
est ce que vous êtes confiants vis-à-vis
de cette équipe de france
vous savez oui quand on voit l'équipe
l'offre
jouer on peut qu'être confiant soucier
tandis le football assad intéressant
c'est que c'est sur le terrain que ça
joue après on peut être les meilleurs ce
qu'il faut c'est d'ailleurs sur et on
verra ce qu'il en est pour l'équipe de
france qui débute sa compétition le 15
juin avec des joueurs en nous le citions
en plus étaient formés dans les yvelines
on peut citer à killian bape et qui est
passé par l'inf clairefontaine mais
aussi les parisiens ou ex parisien qui
pembe koeman radio cons et qu'on était
tous formés au camp des loges à
saint-germain-en-laye alors cet
événement jean pierre meurillon c'est un
peu aussi le retour du football comme on
les aime avec des matchs internationaux
avec un peu de public également dans les
tribunes
j'imagine que c'est attendu aussi avec
impatience par le président du district
de football des i mean que vous n'êtes
absolument ça fait trop longtemps comme
un peut pas jouer au foot faut se
rappeler que ça s'est arrêté au mois de
mars 2020 ensuite ça a repris mais ça
s'est arrêté au mois d'octobre et enfin
au mois de juin à partir de la semaine
prochaine d'ailleurs du prochain
week-end nous avons à nouveau organisé
non pas des compétitions bien sûr mais
des des actions dans le foot que ce soit
pour les féminines pour les u 18 et u 16
les u14 de foot d'animation etc
et pendant tout le mois de juin les
clubs vont en faire rejouer et on va
parler bien sûr de ce retour et de ceux
des confinement du footballeur est ce
qu'un bon parcours ou au contraire un
mauvais parcours peut influer justement
sur le nombre de licenciés à un niveau
départemental dans les yvelines est ce
que ça peut jouer oui ça peut jouer
d'ailleurs ça joue et qu'on savoir que à
la suite de l'euro 2016
on a augmenté notre nom de licenciés
d'un peu plus de 1000 après la coupe du
monde ans après 2018 donc on a augmenté
de 4 34%
ce qui est quand même important et après
la coupe du monde féminine en 2019 on a
augmenté le nombre de féminines de
joueuses féminines de près de 19%
donc on voit bien alors que si on
regarde les autres les autres saisons ça
ne s'est pas du tout passé de cette
façon la coupe du monde féminine qui
était aussi en france wayne
au 31 octobre la fff a accusé une perte
de 123 mille neuf cents licenciés pour
le football animation alors ça c'est au
niveau national à l'échelle nationale
aujourd'hui quelle est la situation en
terme de licenciés est ce que le
football yvelinois a grandement souffert
de cette crise sanitaire du point de vue
des licenciés absolument lors nous avons
perdu nous avons perdu trois mille deux
cents licenciés entre la saison dernière
et cette saison c'est à dire à peu près
8 % mais il faut savoir que la saison
précédente on en avait déjà perdu un
certain nombre également puisque je
rappelle que ça s'est arrêté au mad
marceau 2020 et si on compare la
situation de cette saison 6 avec la
dernière situation quand ils n'avaient
pas le coc vide on a perdu 11 30% de
licenciés ce qui est à dire 4700
licenciés ce qui est quand même de
licenciés et combien licenciés
aujourd'hui dans les yvelines
du coup alors c'est la loge en avant
trente 30 7036 1859 exactement à près de
37 mille alors qu'habituellement dans la
41 je le disais le football amateur on
va reprendre peu à peu ses droits alors
c'était déjà le cas il y avait une
pratique sans contact qui était
autorisée après un accord entre la fff
et le ministère des sports
les mineurs eux ont repris une pratique
normale depuis le 19 mai avec aussi la
compétition qui a pu reprendre pour
est-ce que tout s'est bien déroulé ce
que de petits tournois on va dire à une
petite échelle avec la crise sanitaire
ont pu être organisées depuis le 19 mai
alors oui nous avons attendu bien sûr ça
a été annoncé le 12 mai avec avec la
possibilité de recontacter du 19 mai
nous on a laissé le temps au club de
ceux de s'organiser eux-mêmes et pour
ceux qui ne souhaitaient pas s'organiser
entre eux et bien nous avons organisé
nous mêmes on a demandé aux clubs de
s'inscrire donc sur un certain nombre de
catégories donc le foot d'animation et
puis ensuite les moins de 14 ans les
moins de 16 ans et les - 18 10 - 18
seulement à partir au delà du 9 juin
puisque le premier week-end parce que
les 18 ce genre il y en a qui sont dès
qu'ils sont des majeures donc cela il
fallait qu'on attende de notre choix est
donc dans le
pour tous les week-ends du mois de juin
justement une dernière question sur les
majeurs qui eux vont pouvoir reprendre
une pratique normale à partir du 9 juin
on imagine que la saison prochaine se
prépare est ce que les dates sont d'ores
et déjà fixée pour la reprise des
compétitions où vous travaillez encore
sur le sujet en ce moment alors on
travaille encore sur le sujet parce que
il faut savoir que les les calendriers
dans l'est dans les districts ne peuvent
se faire qu'une fois qu'on connaît les
calendriers les ligues et les ligue
elle-même ne peuvent le faire qu'une
fois que les calendriers des
championnats nationaux sont connus et là
ils sont connus depuis 48 heures on
connaît aussi les premières dates de la
coupe de france par exemple mais pour
l'instant nous nous attendons et bien
entendu on va tenir les clubs d'informer
des cons on aura établi les calendriers
merci jean pierre meurillon d'avoir été
avec nous j'aurai un prix est je le
rappelle vous êtes le président du
district de football des yvelines mais
des jeunes qui sensibilise des jeunes au
lycée 17 mar à maurepas les élèves ont
organisé la première édition de leur éco
festival autour de diverses sources de
pollution exposition sensibilisation et
geste éco citoyen retour sur ce temps
fort dans l'établissement avec mélanie
poké et astrid bergère entre deux cours
les élèves farfouille parmi les rayons
depuis ce matin une friperie a pris
place au lycée 17 mar de maurepas des
vêtements gratuits avec derrière une
sensibilisation à la pollution textile
on veut montrer à quel point la position
textile c'est vraiment une pollution qui
impacte beaucoup l'environnement en fait
c'est la deuxième plus grande pollution
et
et si on voulait dire que par exemple
juste pour créer un jeans et entre 7000
et 10000 litres d'eau potable qui est
gâchée
c'est assez simple de changer notre
manière de consommer surtout dans la
pollution de textile parce que ben en
fait on peut re coût de nos vêtements
qu'on peut les réparer on peut les
personnaliser
et aussi il ya beaucoup de frais prix
qui existe pollution textiles mais aussi
numérique alimentaires et des transports
quatre thématiques sur lesquelles les
lycéens sont sensibilisés accompagnés
par leurs professeurs est organisé comme
un circuit dans un musée j'ai suggéré
l'idée de cette exposition
donc de choc
et les élèves donc les aides du cvl les
éco-délégués tous les élèves avec qui
ont travaillé sur développement durable
ont été tout de suite très partants et
petit à petit on a construit cette cette
exposition des ateliers se sont rajoutés
ce projet qui devait être petit à la
base est devenu quelque chose d'un peu
impressionnant et franchement je tiens à
le dire l'équipe d'élèves qui a
travaillé sur ce projet sont incroyables
tiers qui se sont investis à 300% penser
dès novembre 2020 c'était qu'au festival
est organisé sur deux jours dans
l'établissement mort passe bien à
coignières l'épicerie du centre
commercial le village situé au niveau de
la résidence des acacias fermée
administrativement une décision valable
pour six mois est prise par la
préfecture des yvelines
suite à la sollicitation du maire de la
commune et didier fischer réclamé cette
fermeture depuis un an la raison une
ouverture toute la nuit avec un accès en
arrière boutique et la vente d'alcool et
de cigarettes de contrebande
l établissement crée également des
attroupements et la consommation
d'alcool sur la voie publique écouter le
maire de coignières interrogé par
mélanie poker un épicier qui ouvre toute
la nuit
c'est pas normal d'autant que via un
arrêté de fermeture à 23h donc ils
étaient ouverts toute la nuit
alors ouvert pas forcément d'une manière
très visible avec les séries dos a battu
évidemment et pour qu'on ne puisse pas
voir la lumière à l'intérieur il ya
peut-être aussi d'autres trafics
il ya eu une enquête et évidemment de la
police ces derniers mois mais fermeture
voulu comme première étape d'un projet
de redynamisation du centre commercial
des acacias une concertation aura lieu
en octobre près de la population et
direction à présent neauphle-le-vieux
aurélie égale perreault sont les héros
heureux parents de trois enfants deux
garçons mathis et nathan et une fille
née anna qui est atteinte du syndrome
cardio faciaux cutanée une maladie
génétique très rare comment vit-on saha
parentalité lorsque l'on a un enfant en
situation de handicap c'est notre
portrait du jour signée eléonore si nos
quais et mélanie poker comme tous les
soirs à neauphle-le-vieux aurélie et
gaëlle perron accueillent leur fille qui
rentre de sa journée en institut léana
11 ans est handicapée elle est atteinte
du syndrome cardio faciaux cutanées
c'est un syndrome très rare en fait et
qui impacte à la fois donc sa peau son
coeur et heureusement pour nous les anna
oxa soit au niveau cardiaque ou au
niveau cutané n'a pas de problème
particulier
par contre au niveau de la nourriture de
l'oralité c'est très compliqué
puisqu'elle est nourri par une sonde
déjà parents de matisse 15 ans aurélie
et gaëlle accueille des jumeaux en 2009
nathan et léana cette deuxième grossesse
change alors complètement la parentalité
du couple disons que avec avec son grand
frère
on avait entre guillemets nos habitudes
donc nous d'avoir des jumeaux c'est pas
quelque chose qui nous faisait forcément
peur mais après forcément avec le
handicap ça remet tout en question et
puis c'est des nouvelles habitudes avec
les annales du jour au lendemain tout
peut s'accélérer donc ces êtres savoir
s'adapter et travailler en équipe
je pense que la résilience est quelque
chose d'important pour des parents
d'enfants handicapés parce qu'il faut
savoir avancer avec cette différence et
construire la vie différemment de celle
des autres
à la naissance des jumeaux aurélie cesse
de travailler léana a besoin d'une
surveillance constante
hospitalisé pendant les premières années
de sa vie les médecins ne feront un
diagnostic qu'au bout de trois ans une
longue période de doute d'angoise et
même de culpabilité pour les parents ça
a été trois années très longue pour nous
on était un peu en errance diagnostique
et on essayait de comprendre la
situation ce qu'on avait une petite
fille qui ne s'alimentaient pas savoir
que c'était un syndrome non héréditaire
en fait c'est la faute à pas de chance
voilà les annales a eu ce jeune qui a
muté ça nous a permis à david d'enlever
cette chape de plomb de lever une
culpabilité certaine passé le choc et la
culpabilité la force prend le dessus
après de longues recherches léana est
admise à 6 ans dans un institut
spécialisé prise en charge la journée la
petite rentrer le soir à la maison un
quotidien désormais bien rodée pour les
parents oui on va y aller pour faire
face aussi au handicap de leur enfant
aurélie et gaëlle ont créé une
association en 2015
nommé au fil de léana cela leur a permis
de rompre l isolement
c'était très important pour moi en fait
montré le handicap et de plus sentir en
dehors la société parce que pendant six
années je me suis considéré comme en
dehors de la société avec ma fille pas à
créer
lien autour de nous de bien social et
c'est vrai que ça nous a apporté une
force et moi voilà je refuse de dire que
c'est difficile pour nous pour ces
frères parce que du coup les uns à nous
ouvre beaucoup de choses à d'autres
personnes à d'autres univers et qui sont
très riches avec l'association la
famille c'est aussi découverte une
passion commune le sport entre course à
pied et vélo
de quoi partager des moments hors du
quotidien cet événement se tient pour
une 18e édition rendez vous aux jardins
est au menu à partir de demain vendredi
c'est jusqu'à dimanche
l objectif sensibiliser et faire
découvrir à tous la diversité la
richesse des jardins à cette occasion de
nombreuses animations sont organisées à
saint quentin en yvelines les plus beaux
parcs et jardins de l'agglomération
s'ouvre à vous au gré de balades
commentées de rencontres ou de marcher
un solide programme complet sur le site
du musée de la ville de saint quentin en
yvelines avant de refermer ce journal
connaissez-vous la tricot thérapie c'est
un soin énergétique du cheveu est la
coupe coûte une centaine d'euros et dure
plus d'une heure elle permet de libérer
les tensions présentes dans le corps à
notre journaliste astrid bergère a pu
tester ce soin accompagné d'eléonore
sinoquet le familia voisins le
bretonneux devant le salon de bien-être
de clergé elle qui est coiffeuse
énergéticienne et nous allons était là
tricoter rapide alors c'est une coupe de
cheveux énergétique qui doit harmoniser
le corps et l'esprit
allons voir ça de plus près
nous sommes avec claire gel bonjour
bonjour vous êtes coiffeuse
énergéticienne c'est l'humain quel est
le but final de cette coupe énergétique
le but final de cette coupe de cheveux
énergétique
elle va être de stimuler donc batum au
bulbe pileux de stimuler votre énergie
vitale de des toxines et bush veut vous
apporter un effet bonne mine immédiat
maintenant que vous avez expliqué la
théorie on va passer à la pratique eh
bien avec plaisir je suis
[Musique]
je pense donc la première partie qui est
le massage énergétique kranja où je vais
venir stimuler tous les méridiens et
inviter notre sujet du jour à entrer
dans son monde intérieur
vous posez votre énergie dessus votre
attention que tu y es toute la chevelure
à la marne
[Musique]
je passe à la deuxième partie vous
génère des structures et a le cheveu
stimulante au petit bulbe pileux
je vais vous invitez si vous le
souhaitez à repartir avec vos cheveux et
puis à trouver l'élément qui va
correspondre le mieux cette
transformation à cette conscientisation
nous sommes sur la troisième une
dernière partie health à la
restructuration et l'harmonisation
rasoir je vends qui la chevelure fin de
la sécher et avec le coucou je lis tout
simplement les écailles qui va apporter
beaucoup de brillance de souplesse voilà
la coupe énergétique et déterminer où et
quand je fais plus doux plus ouvre
l'esprit aussi combien il ya de quoi
faire énergéticiens dans le monde nous
sommes 250 coiffard énergéticiens qui
avons été formés dans l'académie de
gilles andrieu merci beaucoup de nous
avoir accueillis
merci à vous voilà c'est la fin de ce
journal merci de votre fidélité et très
belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]